when it comes to the vast universe of
scp it's not unusual to happen upon an
entity from time to time that you aren't
fully acquainted with however scp-1000
goes by a name you're probably more
familiar with bigfoot that's right that
bigfoot the foundation keeps these
creatures under wraps due to the fact
that the simple sight of them will
infect you with this strange disease
that imparts the high probability of you
dropping dead instantly or does it the
fact is the foundation is vastly
overstating the danger of these beasts
for secretive reasons what we refer to
as bigfoots or is it big feet were
actually once a hyper advanced nocturnal
race that threatened to replace humanity
as the dominant species on earth but a
deal with the capricious forest god put
humanity back up on top and reduced
scp-1000 to a tiny population of mere
apes the scp foundation doesn't want you
to know any of this though so they made
up the story about them having looks
that can kill the good news for us is
that it at least seems that scp-1000
doesn't hold a grudge